hallo zusammen wir machen heute richtig
leckeren und fluffigen kaiserschmarrn
haben sie jetzt die geschmeckt alter hut
ist weil es lecker ist aber ich ist das
jetzt sogar und muss sagen die leute
richtig richtig lecker unbedingt
nachmachen dranbleiben und nachmachen
unbedingt und wir gehen jetzt direkt zu
gehör und einfach mit deinen kommentar
[Musik]
wir starten jetzt in dem wir die eier
trennen ich mache das heute ohne
küchenmaschine ist reich vorkommen wenn
ihr euer handrührgerät verwendet denn
das eiweiß muss jetzt schön steif
geschlagen werden und beim eier trennen
einfach immer schön vorsichtig das
eigelb hin und herschieben zwischen den
zwei schalen soll das eigelb kommt schon
mal in die andere schüsse von das eiweiß
werde ich gleich mit dem handrührgerät
schreibt schlagen da gebe ich noch mal
richtig ordentliche prise salz mit dazu
denn erstens 60 das also bis zur
halbzeit und zweitens hebt da jetzt
natürlich den süßen geschmack
[Musik]
sobald das eiweiß so schön steif ist
machen wir weiter mit den eigenen dazu
gebe ich jetzt zucker ganz ganz wichtig
vanille extrakt gibt nochmal so den
essentiellen geschmack einfach und da
gebe ich dann auch schon mehr mit dazu
verrührt das ganz kurz da könnt jetzt
entweder einen schneebesen nehmen oder
er macht jetzt einfach hier mit direkt
weiter braucht auch nicht voll sauber
machen und dann gebe ich auch noch mit
dazu und das alles zu einem glatten teig
[Musik]
für die masse habe ich jetzt auch schön
glatt gerührt und in der reihenfolge
passiert eben auch nicht dass ihr ein
küsschen erhaltet und die milch könnt
ihr auch gerne immer schluckweise mit
dazugeben und bis hierhin habe ich jetzt
vielleicht so 34 minuten gebraucht und
allgemein ist es eigentlich ein
schnelles rezept das heißt wenn ihr
jetzt denkt morgens vom frühstück so ein
aufwand ist es eigentlich gar nicht das
einzige was dauert in anführungszeichen
ist das ausparken in der pfanne und hier
sieht man auch richtig schön die vanille
pünktchen
und in die masse geben wir jetzt unser
steif geschlagene eiweiß rein ich mache
das in zwei bis drei schritten und ich
mache das auch mit einem teig schaber
anfangs hat man das gefühl das verbindet
sich nie weil die masse ebenso flüssig
ist aber er ist einfach immer
weitermachen und dann ergibt es eine
richtig fluffige masse die wir später in
der pfanne auspacken
[Musik]
es gibt viele rezepte da wird
kaiserschmarrn erstmal in der pfanne
kurz ausgebacken dann ab in den ofen
getan für zehn und zwanzig minuten und
dann wird es in der pfanne weit also
umgedreht und weiter gebacken das geht
auch mit meinem vater mir könnt ihr
nämlich ganz einfach den griff entfernen
und die von den backofen tun dass es gar
kein problem aber ich habe mir gedacht
ich mache das lieber noch praktischer
und zeigt euch jetzt mein rezept quasi
nur auf dem herd damit die gar nicht
dieses hin und her habt und es schmeckt
halt genauso gut und für den geschmack
brauchen wir jetzt selbstverständlich
butter ihr könntet übrigens auch
butterschmalz nehmen dann könnt ihr auch
noch wärmer erhitzen ohne dass es euch
an brennt aber reine butter müsst euch
vorstellen brennt wirklich sehr schnell
an und dann schmeckt s nicht mehr und
ihr müsstet quasi alles noch mal von
vorne machen ich nehme jetzt noch mal
ein restauriertes kokosöl mit dazu jetzt
kennt er schon aus meinen videos das ist
einfach kokosöl bio was man sehr sehr
stark erhitzen kann aber dem wurden
geschaltet dem wald geschmack und geruch
entzogen das heißt also es riecht und
schmeckt wirklich noch gar nicht aber
ihr habt den vorteil dass das hoch
erhitzen könnt und zusammen mit der
butter er gibt es noch mal richtig
leckeren geschmack und das werde ich
jetzt einfach mal verlassen ich gehe mal
auf stufe sieben von neun dann gebe ich
die komplette masse da rein und dann
werde ich mit geschlossenen deckel auch
so circa zehn minuten lang garen
[Musik]
ihr könnt übrigens mit der hitze später
noch mal runter gehen auf vier von neun
weil lieber geht auf nummer sicher bevor
es euch von unten halt verbrennt durch
die zu starke hitze ich hab's dann auch
umgedreht und nach dem umbringen braucht
nun mal so drei bis maximal vier minuten
und dann wenn es gar es könnt ihr euch
einfach zwei so küchenhelfer nehmen und
zerrupft es quasi und traditionell wird
das ganze dann natürlich mit puderzucker
bestreut und ich mache da richtig
ordentlich puderzucker trug ich liebe
das ach so ja oder nein wir schon den
handel zum test
[Musik]
jetzt noch richtig die projekte haben
ich habe vergessen oder wird das macht
mich glücklich das könntest du dir
denken war heute kommt gleich verloren
ist mit der süßen das ist
könnte es geben konnten dies klinge ja
ich möchte dem ist ja den habe ich auch
schon mal gemacht ich möchte nicht weil
das schmeckt echt flugfähig ich möchte
aber nicht
das merkst du noch aus aber das ist eine
riesige sammlung außerdem wird unter und
zucker schmeckt lecker ich bin sehr
lecker sogar über scheidung beziehung
gemacht aber weiß natürlich geil in der
es um seine vanillepudding dazu ja so
eine sache dazu
dass auch viele machen es abfinden muss
oder satirischen kirsch kurzer gibt's ja
oft fertig am rock aber
überlegen ob wir die holen sollen den
dritteln da jetzt noch karamellsoße mit
seinen letzten jahren kritisch sauber
das ist guck mal hier das safety safety
fast
immer mehr ankommen wie toll das
aussieht guck mal
bei dir gibst du dir mehr mühe jetzt
wirst du richtig so hin und her naja ich
beschäftigt also macht unbedingt nach
genauen mengenangaben steht unten die
sehr und wir an sonst nicht mal sagen
wir sind out